I used to use the guilt from drinking
to make me feel motivated about training
so I'd be like oh yeah I could drink
Pinot Noir cup you know bottle two
bottle three bottles no problem eat
dinner go to sleep wake up 5 a.m train
like an animal what's the problem no
problem there's a problem I don't see a
problem you could train hungover oh yeah
like an animal
[Music]
yeah man we're live we just we get
things going and I can kind of fill you
in
um you probably don't know anything
about who we are do you
no but that's not unusual I I don't know
much about anything really good hey same
I mean I I've I've learned about you I
mean I I I've uh this podcast is called
my first million so basically I owned um
a fairly successful and big Media
company that I sold and one of our
products was this uh podcast and it's
listened to by millions of people a
month and it's mostly a business podcast
which I'm like a I'm a health nut and a
health nerd I was a former College
athlete so I'm going to talk to you all
about like uh layered superfood and some
of your businesses and stuff like that
that's where we're gonna spend most of
the time but the reason why I wanted to
have you on
was because we have people we normally
don't have guests normally it's my
co-host Sean who's not here and someone
was asking us like who's your dream
guest and I was like man Laird Hamilton
that's who I want and they're like why
and I was like he I had my description
as to why I liked you best but you said
it in another interview a while back you
said something like
your life is like a wheel and like
business is one spoke health is another
spoke uh relationships is another one
and like there's all these Spokes and
like they all have to be nice in order
to make this whole wheel work and I was
like oh man that's describes best why I
like you because you know I like making
money I like being fit I like having a
lovely lovely relationship with my wife
I like doing all this stuff and so uh
I'm pumped to talk to you this is uh I'm
normally never nervous to talk to anyone
but you're like when the first maybe
you're you and Andrew huberman made me
nervous to talk to because like I like I
admire you guys and I look up to you
guys well I appreciate that I'm I'm
thankful for that I was talking to some
friends telling them how I'm pumped that
you're coming on and most people know
who you are
but then for the people who don't I was
I was like well
you know he's done a lot of things so I
don't even know how to describe you that
I was like he started as like a surfer
and then like a big wave surfer then did
some modeling and I always tell my
friends I'm like he's a hunk you
probably recognize his face he's he's a
hunk his face is all like you because
you're you you like represented this
quintessential Surfer but then you uh
evolved where you and your wife now are
quite popular because you guys have this
almost zen-like attitude and so a lot of
people like like me I I Turn to You just
to hear like what's your advice on
living you've also started um layered
superfood you have another uh Fitness
brand what what do you like what would
you say is uh like where are you now and
how do you kind of describe yourself in
a sense or two is to kind of your
professional existence I always you know
because like because of Hawaii the way
we grew up there was a lot of
you know there's a there's I would say
segregation but I think there's a lot of
just a lot of friction because you have
all these different cultures and and I
so my favorite description is somebody
goes well you know like where are you
from or something and I go well I'm a
human from Earth so I'm a human from
Earth and if you're something different
than when then we should probably sit
down and have an incredible conversation
but otherwise let's get past that and
then get into like you know what are
these other things uh that we do you
know and I think it's I think uh none of
us are what we do we we are we are who
we are and then we do these other things
but I do I do like uh I mean listen I'm
the water sports and and and fitness and
and and health and wellness is you know
I've kind of made a a career out of that
and so I do like uh I've been fortunate
to do that that's been been a been a
beautiful thing but I mean I am
concerned about uh you know being
healthy and and living a healthy
lifestyle and you know being a good
example for my children being you know
having a good relationship I just I just
know uh I feel best when I'm when I'm
when I have all those things yeah I
always knew you I mean I remember
watching the doctor uh was it riding
Giants
um and a few and a few other movies uh
with you in it and that's how I knew of
you and then I learned about the layered
superfood the creamer and I was like oh
this is great so I've been a I've been a
customer for years but I never would
have paid you as like a business guy I
remember seeing you maybe it was on some
talk shows or something like that where
you had this like electric
um
yeah the golf board that was that was
awesome and I'm like well he's just like
tinkering and inventing and then I
started looking at then I saw uh Larry
superfoods go public and I was like and
I remember reading the report I was like
oh [__] like I think when you went
public it was doing like something like
40 million a year in sales and I think
it went public at a 400 million dollar
market cap but I was like oh man I never
would have pictured this guy as like
doing this stuff what um
what kind of I I know that it was you
you were just tinkering with these mixes
and a buddy of you a buddy of yours was
like all right let's actually do this
thing but
did you always kind of consider yourself
interested in going into business or was
that just uh what the hell let's just
try it no I mean listed early in my
career uh early in my career in surfing
I I I just I looked at like you know
where the money was like where's the
money in surfing and at the at the time
it was in the apparel
um it was in the apparel business and so
I went at kind of uh I would say 18 19 I
got exposed to the apparel business went
used to work in downtown Los Angeles in
a in a in a a sweatshop learning from a
Korean guy that came to America with 38
dollars in his pocket and had a 10
million dollar Sweatshop business making
denim jeans and kind of learned the
whole cut and sew garment business uh
and real life you know and and got to
exposed to every aspect of it uh you
know I think because of the because I
didn't ever really participate in the
conventional uh aspect you know the tour
of Surfing I was always kind of you know
kind of Rogue in the sense that I focus
on big wave riding I wanted to be a big
you know I wanted to kind of I thought
that that for me was the that was the
thing I was intrigued by that was the
thing I was best suited for
um there wasn't a lot of ways to there
wasn't a platform let's say for me as an
athlete it wasn't like you know NBA or
NFL or you got this huge platform you go
play your wife was was volleyball so
like you guys were both like you're both
like Giants and and small fields which I
I always I'm like dude that's crazy they
turned not even just surfing but big
wave surfing which is still cool but
it's tiny oh yeah volleyball and I'm
like I know both of them I knew I knew
you both individually yeah when we had
one and I think that forced us to be
more creative and you know and and do
what we had to do I always say subsidize
it you know like uh normally you know
you subsidize your surfing with maybe
some excavation work or something you
know you do some other you do another
job Surfers go work at restaurants they
I mean they do whatever they can so they
could be in the ocean like Arnold
Schwarzenegger laying bricks exactly
exactly so you just do whatever you you
do to subsidize your your love but uh
and if you can kind of take both of them
you know if you can turn your work in
you know your or your passion into your
work that's a beautiful thing but we've
had to be creative I think both Gabby
and I have always had to be creative in
our career just because we were in such
Niche sports that it forced us to be a
little bit more entrepreneurial in
general we just with our you know it's
whether we were you know a she-modeled i
model early on I mean I I did some film
work I mean I do we do what we had to
you know we do what we have to do and
then that kind of you know we've had
sponsors and I think in in the evolution
of an athlete you have a tendency to
depending on your brand and and your you
know and what you've you know what
you've done I think you evolve into
wanting to kind of be your own sponsor
at the end right get and and and and
we've been real selective and I mean
it's been I think that that's been a uh
it's contributed to our longevity but
it's also been something that's
encumbered us a little bit because we
just won't do you know we won't just
endorse and promote any anything for
money I just we've been pretty cautious
about things that reflect our
authenticity things that are real to us
and so uh you know and I think that's
what led us to a lot of these these you
know the situation I mean with lyric
superfood especially like I just
wouldn't do other
you know energy drinks and other stuff
that just isn't good for you you got to
promote good [__] no exactly and and and
and and I and you know and so I and I'm
because of my surfing and this and some
of the Feats that I've done and the
Innovations I've done I have some people
that look up to me and so I look at that
as a responsibility to conduct myself in
a certain way uh I want to do that
anyway for my own thing so it's a little
selfish in one sense but but it you know
but like like again layered superfood or
xpt or you know even layered apparel
these are things that you know reflect
Who I Am the the uh and and you know
it's like not every single not every
single uh
you know everything in lyric superfood
is something that that I love I don't
make you know I don't want every flavor
because I have to make flavors yeah I
saw like an interview where someone was
like uh so what flavors do you like you
know like I drink this one and they're
like well I like this one you go I hate
that one or something like yeah
I don't drink that one I like this one
yeah but you have to make stuff for
people you know you have to make stuff
for everybody right right I mean for me
I feel like the more successful the
company can be the the more impact I can
have and are those the three like major
revenue streams which is the superfoods
um it's uh xpt xpt and uh uh clothing is
that like your three main things yeah I
mean I'm always doing other other stuff
too I mean I do I do I do speaking stuff
um you know we have other sponsors that
we work with and so you know those like
the media just like that would be like
the media category yeah there's meaty
there's hair yeah I have a farm uh I
have a farming project right now that
I'm working working on as well and then
and then uh and then there'll be some
you know we I work with uh yeah both
Gabby and I work with Land Rover
um I work with Fremont watches and so I
have some there's media and then there's
like some other sponsorship endorsement
stuff that continues on uh which you
know I think I think part of the reason
why that stuff continues on at this
point in my career is just because first
of all our our authenticity and I'm
continuing also to pursue
um athletic achievements as well so I'm
still doing that that stuff uh and so
that that kind of so there's you know
again there's a lot of um
a lot of spokes in the wheel I remember
um
I saw this interview where you're
talking about uh like taking the company
public and you're like we got to go
there and ring the bell and it was just
so much work and all this paperwork and
I'm shocked that anyone could do this
and at first you guys are flying high
things were going well as of late the
stock has been crushed do you like what
what are those emotions going through
like right now when it's gotten crushed
and do you regret taking it public
because it seems like a good business I
mean you're doing good revenues
um I think this year the growth
um it didn't work out this year I just
read one of you guys most recent reports
I think you changed CEOs
what are the emotions now where things
are changing I mean right now it's a
tough world for we're not alone I mean
so that's kind of nice it'd be like if
it was everything was booming and then
you were having trouble you might be a
little bit like well what are we doing
wrong so there's some of that I mean I
wouldn't change a a bit of it I mean I I
could say
listen coming from my background and and
my
my relationship with like being patient
and you know crashing and wrecks and all
my like all the stuff that I've gone
through
hard to I'm gonna be hard to phase you
know what I mean like I'm I'm I'm I'm my
family's healthy I'm healthy we're we're
good you know it's like I tell Gabby I
go you know we were good we're good now
we're gonna be good like it's all so are
you guys having like conversations when
you're like did you have a significant
amount of your net worth tied up into
the company uh I mean hey well it's I
mean listen this the stock value alone
it was was substantial so it's but again
that's counting chickens before they
hatch and so and I'm that's not that
that's not my world I'm not that's not
I'm not that guy like I'm not that that
because I realize that life is so
temporary that if you think you can
somehow and that and that you really
don't have the kind of control you think
you have everybody I mean so my my my
the university I went through the
University of you know of big wave
riding or the University of the ocean or
the University of the Hard Knocks you
just have a different perspective so I
I've been in you know of course what I
love the stock to be going through the
ceiling absolutely uh but I wouldn't
change going public I I wouldn't go back
and redo it because the fact is is that
that experience right at the end of the
day that experience of going through
that process doing the road show doing
90 Zoom one hour zooms over a three week
period all day long every day and just
all this stuff that we did and and and
and just just that knowledge you just
can't unless you've been through that
no no people can't tell you can't talk
to you like they they can say oh yeah
what's you know or I know what it's like
well no you don't know what it's like
unless you've been through that process
and and and so you can't really
appreciate it and and so for me I feel
like that was an incredible School of
not and and experience that you know if
there's anything you can take with us
there's a great
friend of ours who's a woman judge in
the from the south and she always says
to us invest in experiences because if
there's anything that you might be able
to take from you when you do depart this
earth when you die you know it may be
that I mean you're not taking anything
else so none of this other stuff's
coming with you not the value and the
money and the car house and all the
stuff that none of that stuff's coming
with you the only thing that's going to
come with you is the possibly could be
these experiences that you've gone
through and so for me I feel like what
an incredible thing and we're we're the
C the new CEO we have in there is
incredible
um this is only it's a little bit like
because
and I've and I've done some pretty
brutal uh endurance things in my career
um and and and I and I
I know when when you're digging deep and
and you know that's where all the that's
where all the the building comes from
right that's where all the character
building and the polishing of the stone
happens in when it's when you're you
know down and so for me I'm just like
been here before
probably be here again no problem I mean
here we here we go so it's for me I feel
like this is this is a little bit more
like uh the rough like the I would say
the uh refining you know like you're
getting refined right now and and so
it's only going to help us make
everything tighter make our you know
what we need to do better because if
you're not getting bumped a little if
you're not getting pushed then there's
no reason you know I go I'll give you an
analogy of a like a professional team
you know you have this beautiful team
that you built and you go and you have
an incredible season but then you lose
yeah in the finals and then and then the
next season they break the team up and
they're like well you could have easily
won
but you just you just you broke it up
because you and and the winning and
losing it's it's it's
I mean the difference is nothing the
difference is yeah
yeah so so yeah I mean it's I mean my
biggest thing is just I I need this
business to be successful because the
stuff's awesome I need it I need it I
need it for my friends I need it for
everybody who loves it I like so that's
the biggest you know that's our biggest
our biggest uh you know for me that's
the most important thing is that that we
continue to to supply the people that we
do and we continue to get new people in
there and and you know I think right now
everybody's getting squeezed you know I
think there's a big squeeze on the whole
you know on the whole system so the you
know that's I mean this is this is when
the this is when the tough guys get
going this is when they you know and
ours and and our new CEOs and you know
100 Miler he's a merit like he's a long
distance Runner so he knows how to he
knows how to grind so
will you um I read the story about how
you used to make this stuff
um and you're using turmeric and
everything you're just making this
making what is now layered super food at
home
how much capital Did you invest to get
it store ready and about how long did
that take
it was pretty pretty it didn't take I
mean we you know the unusual thing about
the business was is that
I mean it could have been a couple 20 30
grand or something like that at the most
and that but we went online first that's
why it was really not didn't cost us
much to start we made a you know a
powdered version of my original recipe
and then and then about the third or
fourth rendition through that uh we were
just in there looking like you're mixing
like Coke you just got like you probably
just had some scales at home and a
little Ziploc bag and then yeah exactly
one then yeah and then obviously this is
it and then and then and then uh and and
my friend that I was working with Paul
Hodge was like a startup a really and I
had been working with him on the golf
board on another project and uh and so
you know we and we had what we did we
just started online which was fortunate
like remember your first years of sales
what's that
do you remember your first Year's uh
sales
uh I don't I don't probably
I mean I think it happened fairly quick
but
ah you know
500 Grand or something like that I don't
know something pretty quick but it's but
it happened real quick it was like you
know right away it was like okay 5 10 15
you know it was like we just marched
into you know probably 100 100 150
something like that within or even even
a little bit more after probably a year
I mean if you counted like making
samples you know playing with it getting
every you know package getting some
packages of it going online getting the
people that whole process if you get to
count that within the year yeah
something like that nothing nothing
quick but I mean the traction happened
quickly because good stuff people put
and and I and I was able to tap into
kind of a smaller group of you know
friends I would say friends and
following that that was available to us
and that that helped us uh I think it
would have been a little different if we
were just starting from scratch with no
with no uh kind of nobody there to do
stuff with
and we got a lot of and we got a lot of
response too we were we had a real inner
uh I would say a a good group that was
interactive like they would oh try this
one oh we don't like that one you know
that was engaged with us that helped us
and that was a big piece of it that we
had customers that were kind of more
engaged with helping us uh kind of
refine things I think that was it that
was that was also very useful in the in
the beginning
well you timed it perfectly so like
right now we're in the thick of like a
health Trend like uh you know partially
because like if you go to my Instagram
feed it's like you and like all rip
dudes like you know they're like in ice
bass now which I do and you know it's uh
all we're knees over toes like it's like
we're in like a it's become cool now to
to be healthy and like but you were
talking about in um I read how you were
like dude we've been using ghee for 20
years ghee is popular now you've been
doing a lot of stuff that uh is like
considered eccentric 20 years ago which
is now not quite normal but it's more
normal
you also said that um you're like I'm
obsessed with ideas and like figuring
out what can be uh what's gonna work
what's not gonna work were there any
other ideas other than some of the than
what is now superfood was there any
other ideas that you were tinkering with
where you're like man I think this this
thing that I'm doing on a day-to-day
basis or this food I'm consuming or this
trend that I'm or this thing that I'm
doing now will become more popular and I
should maybe pursue that
well I mean listen stand up paddling I
mean I don't know if anybody knows what
stand-up paddling is but I start I mean
I I did that for eight years alone like
that that thing and that thing was the
fastest growing sport in the world for a
while like it's it's everywhere in the
all in the whole planet I mean as far as
a sport itself
um as a discipline I mean foiling
foiling is another thing that I I was
doing
like we're the first guys to really
stand and and then we're the first guys
to ride that you realize that you could
ride ride waves with foils and now it's
you got foil magazines and there's ten
different disciplines and for those
people that don't know what a foil is
it's an airplane that rides underwater
that that
is attached to a board above so you're
and I know people have seen them you
know at this point you've seen some
either an electric version or some I
mean that's what the electric one yeah
America's cups and all the boats have
gone that that direction as well I mean
most of my stuff has come in sport
um I have you know I I mean you always
have some funny ideas that that you know
that that there's a there's gonna be
three customers or maybe four you know I
mean xpt is another a big you know a big
I mean there's some stuff in xpt I have
this pool training system that that I've
been working on for a while that has is
still hasn't really gained traction uh
just be I mean it's gaining traction but
again but the breathing part of it I
think you have like a breathing part on
the app and like I know a lot of people
who do that that I mean is what's the
app the uh how much does that cost or is
it all free
um no you there's different pieces of
the app there's different stages of it
you can go to xptlife.com and then if
you want the breathing app you know
there's different there's different and
I don't know exactly what they're
charging for the app that the app right
now because we've just came out with a
specific breathing one but there's
there's a bunch of different uh
you know there's different levels of of
your participation and we do it we do a
camp too we do like a a two and a half
day seminar but you know you know what I
have I say about Innovation and ideas is
uh you know it's just a new application
of an old idea I mean you you think for
for anyone to have what they would think
would be an original thought at this
point in humanity is insanity like how
how could you have an original thought
given the fact that there has been
billions of Minds over you know hundreds
of thousands of years that saying and
and and also even in civilizations that
we don't really even know anything about
so the thing that you'd have and then
you you know kind of some unique thought
I think it's more about these hybrids
these come combining existing things
maybe some new materials kind of or some
new stuff changes the way I mean listen
my my whole thing around like for
example with Laird uh with superfood is
really based on using plants in our on
the whole form and not separating and
taking you know elements out and
concentrating it or trying to figure I
mean a lot of that's based on really
trying to figure out how to get a patent
and control and own yeah I feel like
listen Nature Made it perfect for your
body
why don't you use it in those ratios and
and it seems like whenever we don't do
that as close to Nature as we can
there's always a problem there's always
a problem whenever you're whenever
you're giving the system something that
it can't really relate to and I think
that that's you know uh I mean at least
in in in in in the superfood side of
things that's a big that's kind of a
philosophy that we use to help govern
that that that brand I mean part of the
reason why I think there's such a crazy
Health thing it was going that way
anyway but I think people started to
realize after the uh you know I mean
since the pandemic happened and that
that being healthy is really an
advantage you know and I think because
we have so much uh like like we're in
somewhat of a Health crisis just given
you know diabetes and obesity and just
all this stuff that's that's been
happening uh I think that that the
importance again back to what I said
earlier about putting value on things
you know you put a value on eating
really good food you're gonna have
really good food if you just are like
hey just get that in you know I don't
care what it is you know let's just you
know go through a drive through and pick
it up and just eat it because we we're
hungry and we want to get full versus no
I want something that really tastes
amazing and has you know and is and is
nutrient dense and all that stuff so
again I think we give the value to the
stuff and that will bring you know
that'll bring the level and the quality
of it but if you don't make it important
then and I just I mean yeah I just think
that that the and then I have a
philosophy about stuff that you do every
day anyway like things that you do every
day are accumulative right there's an
accumulation I mean I mean there was a a
technique they used to use to kill the
king things in the old days is you just
give them a little arsenic right and
then eventually you know in a year or
two all of a sudden the king croaks and
dies but it was never enough to just be
POI it wasn't poisoned but it was just
an accumulation and I think you know I
think that that's true with Fitness I
think it's true with with uh you know
with your diet if you're just you know
if you're if you're eating a little bit
of bad food every day that's an
accumulative thing if you're eating a
little good food every day you know and
uh then that's an accumulative thing and
I think that's your I think that that
there's an opportunity to to really have
an impact on your on your health if
you're just you know hey I'm doing it
I'm doing some training every day I'm
you know I'm getting a good night's
sleep every day I'm getting I'm getting
eating good food every day it's like
this stuff over time is gonna pay
dividends and it's and it you know it's
it's a I mean I I just think that that
really speaks back to the philosophy
about being patient and being you know
you're gonna I told you the story when I
worked in downtown L.A with the you know
know that with that Korean Guy Mr Chun
what brand what brand were they making
stuff for he was making uh oxygen
um he was building guests and green line
so he's building all the guest jackets
where they were made out of like old
Levi jeans they were they'd take jeans
and they'd sew them all together and
then they'd Stone wash it like a just
like a big Factory with Koreans and he's
just paying them nothing I mean well
more yeah but exactly yeah but I mean
probably paying them and paying them
enough that they were able to support
their families and and uh but he was had
like I said big you know uh tumbling uh
washers and dryers with pumice stone but
I'd sit in the end and try to pick stuff
out I'm like I want to pick some wisdom
out of this guy so when I'm sitting
there one day and he'd always drink
Miller Millers he would drink Millers
which is the worst beer ever but that's
another story that's what I used to
drink Miller Light Miller Light that was
my drink it had high alcohol content and
low carbs exactly yeah yeah because
that's so great it's the worst but he he
said you know he goes oh yeah when good
times here don't be too happy because
after a good time bad time comes but
when bad times here don't be too sad
because after after bad time good time
come again and I'm like there's some
wisdom there I mean that means
technically you'd be numb if you didn't
react to things but there is wisdom in
the hey you know when bad times here
don't be too sad because after bad time
good time come and when you're in the
good time don't be too happy so in a way
I think there's something to be said
about that
can I ask you about your house I I've
I've studied or I've I've seen your
house in the setup and I've talked to a
ton of friends you're like oh yeah we
went to Laird's which is you're you're
like you're you're like the Bono you
know you're a one man you're a one-name
guy now which is cool but they're like
oh we went to layers and we did the pool
thing and it was amazing and like one of
the things that you've done is like
you're living like every like many men's
fantasy which is to have this amazing
house that's like community and uh yeah
people coming and going and it's all on
your terms and I think it's pretty cool
um what year did you buy that house and
how much did it cost would you like you
know when that was yeah I mean it was
well I don't know I don't remember exact
figure but it was cheap for Malibu crazy
but we've been here for 25 years 20 26
years so you know what's the values of
of you know what I mean things for a
million dollars 25 years ago or 25
million now
well is that a big deal for you at the
time yes oh yeah oh yeah I mean when
Gabby when I when we looked at that
house because it was the guy had built
it for his
the guy who built the house built it for
himself and and he was a Greek engineer
the one here in Malibu uh because I also
you know I'm from Hawaii and so we have
a home there we just we we just finished
during the pandemic but he was building
for his house his his family and then he
and then during the process I think him
and his wife kind of had got divorced
which happens a lot to people because
building houses is very stressful like
it's a very stressful thing but I said
to Gabby I go I showed her the house and
she looked at the price I go don't look
at the price look at the house just
think if you want the house like before
you look at the price to let it affect
you whether you want the house or not
look at the house because you know
sometimes I think we get in the way of
oh well that's how much it is I can't
get that and dictate instead of well no
so let's see if you want it or not like
why would it even matter what the price
was if you didn't run it anyway so first
let's see if you want it so we went we
came and looked at the house and she was
like oh it's amazing and I stood across
uh at this house I stood across the
street I didn't come into the house and
I just looked and I could see the ocean
I could see this wave that I love to
Surf and so I just and I was like I love
this house and she's like well you
haven't been in the house yet and I go
you're like I don't need them in I don't
even need to go in the house I'm good if
you're good I'm good because I could be
on a you know I could have been on a you
know in a tent right there looking at
the at it so that you know the the what
do they say about real estate
and rest probably restaurants too but
real estate is and houses location
location location location location
location location it's all everything's
about location if you're if you're if
people are trying to buy things and for
value or keep value or have an increased
value it's all about location I mean you
can always change the house you can
rebuild the house but you can't change
where it is and so I I think you know
that's one thing about when you grow up
in Hawaii and you live in an environment
where people work all year to save up to
come on vacation for one week and then
you live in that environment you kind of
I mean if you don't if you have your
head screwed on correctly you realize
what how fortunate that is you know that
that that's a fortunate thing to be that
though and those and that those are to
be cherished those places that yeah that
people seek out to just you know be able
to go there for a week and you live
there that's a pretty that's a pretty uh
fortunate thing but also that you you
need to realize that that's that that
means it's a special place you know I
always see videos of these athletes
coming and going how many days a week
are you actually having people come and
do those workouts in the pool well Gabby
does her she has training in the morning
it depends on the time of the year you
know normally uh most of this is in the
summer time because you have football
basketball a lot of times it's off
season guys come you know I have uh just
I'm connected with a lot of different
athletes and a lot of different coaches
and a lot of different physios and so
people you know guys get hurt
um and then they're coming out of an
injury and then they'll send them to
come see to see you know to see us uh
are you charging them or is this just
like you're just doing it for fun no
it's no because it's if you if if you
charge people then it's the the dynamic
changes you know we really we like to I
like to have that sign that says we
reserve the right to refuse service to
anyone like kind of thing like I think
that that's a better that's a better
relationship I mean we don't have to we
don't we don't need too so it allows us
we have the luxury to be able to not
have to charge because we're able to you
know we're we're there's other ways to
to earn a living and so
um but that does set up a really nice
environment I have like I have a young
uh a young man that's been living with
us and and training training
um and learning about training he's
becoming you know very uh
versatile and just advanced in because
he has such exposure uh and so like
he'll I'll we'll get guys to come in and
guys that want to get get work you know
worked with I'll have him uh and we have
other other trainers with xpt and we
have other people that we know that hey
if somebody needs a trainer and they and
they want to run through a lot of this
the stuff that we do we'll we'll you
know what do we say we have people for
that but yeah we have people for that
that do that and then the rest of it you
know normally we kind of have a communal
training uh you know like on on on
certain days of the week we have some
kind of regulars that kind of come and
train on those days uh you know we do
like it'll be maybe lifting and and
stuff and dry land stuff on on uh you
know like Monday Wednesday Fridays and
then Tuesday Thursday Saturdays is is
can be the pool stuff depending on on uh
on who it is and and what we what we do
and it's it's not a lot I mean there's
at times there could be a fair amount of
people
um you know the the stuff that we do
does weed out some of the people just
because it's you know we're we're we're
here to work and and it's and it's uh
and we have a you know a big probably
the most important piece of it is this
community right that we have a little
that we have a really nice community
that that that's what you realize that
we all are looking for right we're all
looking for a little tribe to belong to
I mean that's I would I would uh blame I
wouldn't say blame but I'd say that that
was part of the success of something
like CrossFit that it was really had
less to do with the working workout
itself as it did that you were part of a
tribe and you had a community and people
that were like-minded that were training
with you and so on so I think that's a
big piece of it I think that that uh you
know that we need that yeah I mean
listen some days you're just down and
you're like hey you know I don't feel
like doing anything today and then
somebody's out there okay ready to go
and then you're like okay let's go and
then you just so you know and vice versa
they might not be and you are and so I
think that we we kind of lift each other
up I think that that's part of I mean we
humans are communal creatures and I
think we operate well that way as long
as we have like-minded people
um I was looking at like some old photos
uh of of folks in your pool I think
there was like uh
and yeah you had a whole bunch of
basketball players yeah joking Noah
Grant Hill a few other people who who
have you worked out with back there that
has uh put you in awe of of their
Fitness or their athletic ability I mean
listen I get so many crazy guys I think
I I mean my problem is I probably have a
skewed bar like my you know I don't
because I'm with normally I'm always
with all these freaks right so it's a
little bit like
hard to out Freak the freak you know
like you when you got you know I got
when you guys got you got you know guys
like Chris McCaffrey or or or you know
or Jalen or I mean just you just have
the level of athlete that you have is I
mean I think there's some there's always
you know the the the the
the people that surprise you are
probably people you haven't heard of
that that come there that that have a
certain mindset because some of the pool
stuff that we do can be it's stressful
you know and so sometimes you know you
you'd think you'd get this big super
strong guy and he freaks out and then
you get some kind of more frail
you know lady that just has a you know
Mental Giant and can just handle you
know being in the ice and drowning in
the deep end and you know so it doesn't
I think it's pretty uh
that's why it's kind of neutralizing
there's a neutralizing aspect to the
environment because it's first of all
you're always going to have somebody
that you know you're always gonna
you're always gonna you're always gonna
have somebody that can out you do you in
something right you can outdo them they
cannot do you and so our approach is
more about you finding your own barriers
and then trying to lift those up right
you try to you try to and and don't use
other people as a reference to you I
think that's where we run and try you
know we get in trouble is you start
comparing you get over there and you're
like okay that guy's doing this and
which what do they say comparison is the
depth of Happiness I'm not sure but joy
something like that man I I I've always
hated that phrase when they say
comparisons of thief of Joy because I'm
like yeah that's true I shouldn't
compare myself but I love to compete and
so like well that's you know but that's
different that's different comparing and
competing yeah
like I like seeing guys and I'm or in
business and I'm like this person's
doing this Revenue they're at 50 million
I'm like oh that dumbass could do that I
definitely could do 70. let's crush them
or like I've got a joke I'm like
people like oh you gotta let go of that
Grudge and I'm like this Grudge fuels
everything I do I've like I like the
reason I like work out hard is to like
prove my ex-girlfriend from high school
that like you were worthy yeah yeah you
made a mistake yeah look everything I do
is because everything I do is because of
a grudge I'm like rage is the greatest
feel on Earth and so when people say
like comparisons to Peep and joy I'm
like I get so much joy proven like these
idiots wrong and like letting a 20-year
comment sit on my back for those years
about how I wasn't like you know fit
enough or successful enough like I love
that stuff you know what I mean yeah but
you will but you know what interesting
because that's I I will say because I
can relate to that I mean listen a lot
of what I've done is because of that
like so but then at a certain point then
you get to this thing and then you're
like okay then what then at some point
you achieve the thing you're trying to
do you prove your point and then you're
sitting there going okay now what and
then you're like okay do I have to make
up a new one or maybe I can create
motivation out of out of of success or
contentment or something versus so I
think there is two I think that can be I
know for myself personally I've gone
through you know being driven and
motivated uh to achieve certain things
because of you know frustration and
proving the work to the world and and
you know and all those things that I
went through that drove me but then but
then you achieve it and then you're like
okay now what you know what am I gonna
do now like now how I'm gonna adjust to
be able to continue and so if at least
in my I can say Hey you know and
listen if you're a competitor you're a
competitor that's just a vicious like
for me I think I'm I'm such a vicious
competitor that
that I would I almost I can't I can
barely actually even compete because I
just because of because in in a real if
you look at real if you look at
competition in nature
and the brutality of it like the real
like the real thing not just these
contrived things of like the real like
for real
yeah then you're like okay well maybe I
better figure out how to constructively
vent that stuff do you does that does
that does that carry over to to business
too I mean are you talking uh I think
Mike I think I think his name's Mike
your new CEO are you like you know we
need I want this much profit we need
this much growth does that carry over to
business as well yeah I mean not not
that not that way no I mean it it you
know I mean it maybe it should but it
not that I think it's mine is a more
you know mine is a patient thing like I
have a like I you know my favorite term
is the victory through attrition
there's be a cockroach that's like like
like the last guy standing like I'm all
about that like you can be like yeah
yeah yeah you can have your little wins
your little wins and your little wins
and all great but I'm talking about like
at the end when you're the only one left
on the battlefield and everybody's
laying on the ground then you don't even
have to be any good
you don't even have to be good you're
just
Undisputed you're the guy because so and
I think I think for me I feel like and
and I'm looking at the greatest
competition
is life
right the greatest competition is life
like you want to talk about the real
game the game the real game like because
all these other things
they're games they're right but the real
game the big game is life the big game
is you know is
like the quality of like at the like
relationship
father you know how like your life like
that's the big game that's the real game
that's why I said when I talk about the
spoke I go yeah business that's one
spoke make sure it's nice and tight good
cool but if you're all there then you
got these giant holes in the other spot
I'm like sorry lost the game already but
you you
you've not always been that way have you
I think I read some old stuff where like
I think your wife filed for divorce and
one at one point and you guys like
you've thankfully made it work I think
an 0-1 yeah I think you I don't I don't
remember if I read that you had a
drinking problem but I think you said
that uh you wish you had told your
younger self to quit drinking earlier so
I don't know if that was like a problem
or not uh like I know that you and if I
just were just a stereotype you I'm like
I bet you were like a wild guy and
anyone if I'm stereotyping a surfer who
like goes out hard it does everything
hard I'm like I'm sure I bet you picked
some of your vices uh with that same or
you use that same energy sometimes
toward devices when did did were you
kind of like uh you weren't always this
wise I'm sure and what made that switch
well no I mean well okay let's let's be
let's be clear that
for sure work right sure work in process
work in process now working process then
I mean I I always
you know love sleep I always like even
within my I mean I the thing like my
thing about drinking like I love I love
wine I drank I that was when I always
said I had I had two French habits
because I worked with a French company
for 20 years and my two French habits
were espresso and Pinot Noir and then it
was like and and
like every thing I do I have a tendency
to do it you know in excess like if
one's good then two is better so that's
the mentality and so in a way but as far
as like as far as kind of my I mean
listen at first of all I would have
never first I never Gabby and I would
never have gotten to be together if I
didn't have a certain if I had didn't
have a certain
I'd say calculation morality values I
mean there's certain things that were
that I've had my whole life right that
since I was since I was young it wasn't
like I got them I had I had the basis of
it and then that's been just a process
of refinement again oh loose spoke like
hey you know what this this this
drinking thing's an issue because I
don't have real power over it I want to
prove to myself I do I come from a you
know I always say I come from a long
line alcoholics but we all do I think
it's a human you know I I always say out
being alcoholics like being a surfer
there's no one that doesn't love surfing
well there's no human being that doesn't
actually like alcohol it's just whether
you die I love it too I'm uh yeah I'm 10
years sober too yeah I loved it so I got
15 here I got 15 not but but my thing
was like a you know my mom said to me
once when I was a kid she said if you
can't be true to yourself you can't be
true to anyone else and so I thought let
me see if I say hey I can stop drinking
anytime and then
the next day I drank or the next week or
the or the next month then I really
don't have a lot of power over right so
then I want to have so now I want to be
like I want to have some power over it
and so that was a discipline thing too
and you know what I saw also said in all
the dumbest things I ever did were when
I was drinking that all the stupidest
things I ever I've ever done usually
some alcohol was somehow involved in
there because because it like it says in
the bottle impairs your motor skills so
so let's not forget so and so in in in a
way uh those things like the in my
relationship the rocky times and
relationship those refined you know and
and and motivate you to make changes you
know all those things okay the drink in
the thing you know like just all these
different these things that and there's
things I'm still working on and probably
will always be but that's a continuation
of of trying to to uh
get better like get get get better and
not and and which means that you're
saying hey there's things that you think
you could do better or you could be
better or you could make changes or you
could you know whatever whatever those
are I mean they're you know what do they
say about Sin you know let he without
sin cast the first stone no one seems to
be able to throw one because everybody
falls short so I mean it's about being
honest too like being honest with
yourself and being like okay what is it
what it what do I what is it which which
thing and then you know what you just
start eliminate you start okay let me
let's work on that one let's work on
this one and then and then as you go and
so that's I mean I'm in that I'm in that
in that uh process and and and and and
then you get success you get you get you
get success I mean I use I used to use
the guilt from drinking
to make me feel motivated about training
so I'd be like oh yeah I could drink
Pinot Noir cup you know bottle two
bottle three bottles no problem eat
dinner go to sleep wake up 5 a.m train
like an animal what's the problem no
problem there's a problem I don't see a
problem you could train hungover oh yeah
like an animal oh [__] that you puke in
the ocean using that using that guilt
using that guilt and prove like approved
like all proof let me show you what a
man I am you know I'll show you what I
can do and so I I hope your pool had a
good filter man
the worst but but like I said my
drinking problem had to do with wine
only never a hard you know I mean okay
not never hard booze but I was pretty
smart about that but uh uh but even
within that I had you know there was
some sort of control but I'm just
speaking in general as a thing to refine
right as you go let's just try to let's
try to continue to to to polish the
stone
[Music]
see most crms are a cobble together mess
but HubSpot is easy to adopt and
actually looks gorgeous I think I love
our new CRM our software is the best
HubSpot grow better
you're kind of going like one path down
this longevity thing and healthy living
thing that I love but I love freak shows
I love like people who are just oddballs
and a guy we had on here one time his
name's Brian Johnson have you seen Brian
Johnson from blueprint I mean he's like
total freak Show when it comes to
longevity and I love that people are
brave enough to do what he's doing
because like you can always learn cool
songs when you're doing extremes isn't
he blending his food every day I think
Gabby did a podcast on him is that the
guy he he's doing all time yeah that's
basically he's liking everything yeah
he's like I'll like give you I'll give
you like the the clip notes but
basically he's uh probably close to a
billionaire so he started a company that
he sold so he's got plenty of income and
money to like be playing around but
basically he's like I want to become the
most tested person on planet Earth and
I'm gonna try to he goes I'm gonna try
to uh decrease my biological age faster
than my chronological age which
obviously is going to be impossible at
one point but he was like let's just see
if I can get make my body younger even
though my age gets older and so he like
does crazy amounts of tests where he's
doing tests weekly and he's spending
millions of dollars doing it and he
blogs and documents it all on his
website blueprint but some of the crazy
stuff that he's doing is he's like well
through my tests are showing that like
this vegan diet or vegan lifestyle is
working well for me therefore I am only
going to eat these same three things
every day and he like measures the
calories down to like the thou he's like
you know it's got to be this amount of
calories this servings the workout has
to be this and I'm like I love that
weirdos like that exists because we're
gonna be able to learn some cool stuff
from him have you been paying attention
to that and what do you think about
those people that are a little bit less
I mean he I don't know if he's like I
think at one point you said um science
follows intuition with him it's like
let's go science and let's see how that
makes me feel uh but have you been
paying attention to that and what's your
what's your take well Gabby did a show
on on Brian and uh a podcast went and
interviewed him and and so here and I
have a conversation when she kind of
filled me in about some of the stuff
that he was doing did she go to his
house she did yeah she didn't she ate
something she ate some of his goulash
she ate some of his The Nutty yeah his
Blended blended it and I mean listen you
know when you chew food when you chew
food you create saliva that you create
enzymes in your mouth that go down with
the food to help digest the food and the
one of the worst if one of the ways if
you really want to become like allergic
or have a an allergy against something
is just eat that alone every day all day
but but that gets into I'm into a whole
you know I'm I I'm into I guess for me I
just feel like you can't hack your way
around
biology in my in my in my world of my
thought and it is interesting I think
you can use hacking to support work you
know I think I think uh first of all I
think in the diet one of the most
important things is diversity I think
that's one of the most important I mean
the problem is is it's hard to to not
get bombarded by a bunch of you know
things that aren't good for you as well
but you know through that so
it'll be it'll be it would be
interesting to to I mean Gabby would be
a better person to have the conversation
about but I am always interested in
watching I think there's so much
uh I don't know he I mean I do
appreciate that he's doing like the guys
going through going through it but but
as far as you know what
what
you know were what we are and what we're
doing and what we need I'll be
interested you know I'll be interested
to see uh
first of all what would it what it you
know what it does
I um I think more as an entertainment
that's what I'm saying like I I love
that like uh I don't know if you pay
attention to fighting but you know who
uh Nate do you watch fighting like MMA I
don't I don't watch a lot of it I know I
know I have a bunch of guys I know that
do it but I I yeah I mean I I like I I
always say I love a freak Show I like
fighting boxing I mean I love just like
what do you think about Crazy Event what
do you think about uh uh wrestling WWE
wrestling or WWE I I mean I love that
stuff do you watch that what's that oh
yeah we'll have a friend of mine my
friend or mine bring brought me to it I
never even watched it and I have a
friend that really is into it and so he
he he brought me and I go with him but I
only I live vicariously through him
because I'm Amazed just how how Intuit
he is how much he knows about it it's
just a grill man soap opera
no it's fun I love this tour you know it
goes to our deepest it serves a purpose
oh yeah it does it goes right to that
joke guy in his underwear it's like
fighting and arguing about [__] you know
what I mean like let's just like I just
like I like me I like weirdos I like
freaks just like let it be well and also
people from outside really they think
they actually think that the audience
thinks that everything what's going on
is real they don't realize that
everybody in the audience knows exactly
what's going on and they're just
participating in the whole show and then
it's all the fun whole thing it's pretty
so yeah the humans are I mean listen
humans are entertaining and and you know
just watch them when you're like I uh I
have this like image in my head of of
what you are uh and like you running
your businesses I'm like is he like
totally out of the picture on a database
on a day-to-day basis and just talks to
the CEO once a month and I was like
actually what's that what would that
look like like when we got on here your
uh wife helped set up the camera are you
even using a computer or a phone on a
daily basis are you totally detached
yeah no I'm I I'm I'm I use a phone uh
I'm not
I'm not I'm not a social media a guy I
don't spend very I mean this is my the
phone for me is communication
weather weather and news and new and new
stuff that that and when I say news I
mean more like investigation stuff like
but but I mean listen I I'm what's
investigation stuff uh just trying to
understand what the truth is about
whatever and everything so they just it
just I'm I I go into if I'm interested
in something if that you know if I'm
interested in some political thing I I
like to look like understand exactly
from my own not just take the the advice
of people that are telling you about it
but actually like understand the real
stuff so I have a tendency to but I'm
just using like I said the thing for a
tool so I I hardly I hardly use it I
talk to Jason all the time I talk to uh
you know blurred apparel uh the lady you
know the lady that's that's running that
right now yeah I'm in communication with
these because because it's first of all
it's got my name on it so it you know
it's it's has to do with my brand and
and we're just we're vested in the in in
it and interested in it so we're I mean
all this the the uh I mean I'm all also
yeah I mean we're we're we're we're
we're we're we're we're we're we spend
you know we're we're multiple times a
week if not every single day I'm
communicating with those Brands uh and
and you know either discussing okay
promotional this or or product
development or you know whatever
whatever yeah we're we're so I um
I uh I I think I told you I I had
started this company and sold it and uh
when I was 30. so I was able to like uh
financially get some some some really
nice security there yeah and I look at
the type of life that you live where
um so I also I split time between Austin
and New York my wife's from New York and
so we we spend there all the time and I
have a handful of projects uh that I'm
working on I got a a company with a CEO
that runs it so a a bit similar ish to
what you're doing and God willing some
of them will be huge what I'm curious
about because there aren't that many
people in the situation where I want to
go to
um and where I'm in now but you
definitely are uh which is how do you
break up how are you how do you map out
your personal finances so because you
said that you have this one Farm as a
project you have three or four five
different businesses right now you have
two or who knows what you have how much
real estate do you just like is there
just like one Revenue stream where
you're like that's just the like for
example the app might have high margins
so you're like oh we'll just live off
that or media appearances I bet you I
can just pay I can make a million bucks
a year and that will be what I live off
of and then all the rest I'm gonna
reinvest or I'll put into the a Vanguard
just normal Index Fund how does that how
do you balance all your different things
when it comes to a personal finance
space uh uh I mean well I first of all I
have
smarter people at that than me so I have
I have I have I have P you know I have
advice people that that you know I have
specific specifically a woman that I
work that we've worked with for a very
long time that does like you know
management that that sort of stuff I
would say
uh
accounting and and Finance Management
just because that's
she's into it and and and good at it and
that's what she's interested in so we we
have it we have that you know that's a
big a big piece of it I I think that uh
you know I I think one of the
I mean for me personally
I don't I I think that that can be a a
such a consuming hole like that all of
that stuff that you can just get
swallowed into that and and lose
every you know lose your connection with
everything as well I think that you have
to I I you know well part of it has to
do with how you look at it like what's
your what's your you know what's your
faith you know like what kind of Faith
do you have what kind of belief do you
have that everything's
going well or not going well and you
think that you're going to control
everything and that you know how much
control do you think you have and all
those things I think that's a piece of
my I think of my My Philosophy
um what so does that mean that you just
don't stress out a significant amount
about finances and like earlier you said
when I bought that house you're like oh
that was a lot of money for us back then
but I was like [__] it we're doing it
anyway we'll figure it out yeah that's
kind of like your your how you live when
it comes to finances yeah which is which
I I think for a lot of people they just
can't operate like that and I think I
think I think for me I just feel that
just feels more
that just feels better I I I just feel
that feels more natural I just feel that
you know because the because
I I just you know I've Just Seen I've
first of all I've had I've had the
fortune to be exposed to a lot of
wealthy people in my life like a lot of
crazy wealth and and and seeing people
that had no nothing and all of a sudden
they got everything and I've seen people
with everything and they lose everything
and so I've gotten to watch a lot of it
and I just feel like you know there
there's a level of imprisonment that
happens when you when you
you know and and I think I mean a lot
that's why when I say faith I mean you
know they talk about about you know you
you saving up you know in your Warehouse
with you know where moth and rust can
eat you know like you know like there's
some stuff to do with that I think which
I think you can't
you can't oh it is not so simple to to
to be that way and I think it's harder
for uh you know I think it's a it's a
hard it's hard for people to to to
operate like that but having that you
know having that belief it's like people
talk about visualization and visualizing
and you know having that I mean it's
real that's that's the real stuff like
if if you think it's not real you're
you're mistaken that you you you you
thing you can you can make things
your belief in it definitely will be
supportive of it happening I can tell
you that for sure in both ways right
like in both ways you can make things be
you know like Gabby says if you have an
ouch God will give you a hurt you know
if you walk around going ouch ouch ouch
you'll be surprised if stuff isn't just
hitting you all the time and so and I
think vice versa it's the same way the
other way which is you know uh what is
that if you know yo Yi of little faith I
provide for the birds you don't think
I'll provide for you like so there's
some of that that's real stuff like they
didn't just make that stuff up out of
the sky that's a real that's real thing
so I think there's something to be said
about that doesn't mean be stupid and
you know when doesn't mean just uh you
know just ignore your your reality but
but there is something about that that's
real that that I think can put you in
the right State of Mind to not just be
caged by this stuff because this is the
caging area that's an area that we can
be cage and I'm I'm one of them I'm I I
get I'm caged by it's like when I I was
broke and then I was not broke and I'm
like oh [__] I've just like created a
prison a little bit where you get where
you stress out over running out yeah
yeah we're scarcity creatures right so
we have this whole scarcity thing that's
in us right so so and you know my mom
had another good saying which was be uh
the way God punishes you is he gives you
what you ask for
so be careful what you ask for because
you go hey I just want that you know I
want that big house and then you're like
yeah and then all of a sudden with that
house comes all this other stuff like
all the stuff that comes with it which
means that there's a bunch of stuff to
break and there's a bunch of thing and
there's a bunch of stuff to maintain and
there's a you know it's so it and you
know and that could be overwhelming I
think I think that you know that's why
you see these guys that are these big
these big hitters they're they're kind
of they're not bogged down by all that
little stuff right they're not they're
looking in they're looking in in a at a
bit at a bigger
um a bigger thing but that being said
you know uh
you know like I said there's there's
something about being prudent in and
having the right people around you that
could that that you because it's it
takes it it takes a what do they say it
takes a village but it you know you got
to have you got to have people that to
help because there's not you can't do
everything you can you know and it's
like and so that you you need to be
you're only as good as you know as The
Company You Keep so I think that that's
another important piece too like people
well uh
no I mean and that that's one of the
reasons why I look up to we've had um I
don't know if you know what Rob Dyrdek
is but he's pretty amazing where uh he's
another guy where I'm like Laird and Rob
they've nailed it where business nailed
it
personal life you never have totally
nailed that but you like are do really
well Fitness nailed it like
self-awareness nailed it
um I know you uh we'll wrap up here in a
minute but my last question was um
I think last year on your guys's YouTube
Gabby asked you what are your goals for
it was at the end of 2022 she said what
are your goals for 2023 you go uh this
year I want to be more of a Savage I
want to be more set I want to do more
Savage stuff like I want to get like
dirty and do something what as an
example we're we're more than halfway
through the year what's an example of
something that you've done so far that's
Savage and you also talked about
visualization over the next six months
and 18 months are there any particular
experiences or goals that you're trying
to do that would be that would check
that box of being more of a Savage
well I mean I'm I mean listen I have the
nature I have for me here I'll I'll give
you an example for me I've always wanted
to kill an animal I wanted to go and
kill a deer or some type of I have cows
in my Ranch I was like I want to
slaughter it with my hands and I want to
eat it I was like I don't do that enough
and I eat a ton of meat I gotta do that
yeah and like that's my that's that's an
example for me which is not that very uh
that's not too Savage but what do you
have well I go for I go uh I go for
moose you know I go for a move I go for
probably in September I'll be I'll go
get a moose and and so I can feel the
cool fill the freezers for the winter
but I grew up at a farm too so I'm
already I've dealt with the you know and
I've hunted when I was a kid we hunted
boar and stuff like that I mean for me
that the Savage stuff comes more with
the with the with the ocean you know
like with with the conditions
um I had one trip already to uh
uh I had one trip to Peru this summer I
mean we're just my my most of my Savage
stuff comes from the environment so I
need to you know and and and normally
you know I mean listen I I just we had
that giant Malibu fire
um I had to I had I fought my house for
you know I fought that I saw that four
or five hours with a suit and a pump and
and then I had a flood in Hawaii after
and I was like you know at night with
boats it you know rescuing people off
the top of their roofs to their houses
and stuff and so I have to be careful
um what I asked for
because before both of those things I
said I just need some action you know I
just so again you know back to what my
mom said be careful what you asked for
be careful oh yes yeah you got to
clarify so you have to clarify what uh
you know what what that what that is you
know I think it's because it's easy to
make a blanket statement I just wanna
you know it's like I said when I was
young I wanted to be surrounded by women
women uh you know that goalie I just
want to be surrounded by women like and
then well now you are right yeah yeah I
have three daughters so you know again I
should have been a little more uh uh how
clear in my defi definition
do you read a lot of books
um I listened to a lot of books but I
read I read some and I'll read and
listen but I but I listen to a lot
what are the best two that you've
listened to in the last 12 or 18 months
so
um well I did I did I liked uh there was
a book called Life After Life
that I really
um I I really enjoyed
um by uh what's his name Moody
um and then uh
let me see the uh
you know there's a there's a gnarly a
really pretty heavy one called Embrace
The Fearless uh embrace fearlessly the
burning World by uh Barry Lopez he's
he's pretty radical
um
and then
I went I went full conspiracy
uh oh actually the the psychology of
totalitarianism was pretty was a pretty
heavy book that's the one you were
referring to when you said you went full
conspiracy no the the full conspiracy
was called The Trap
that one's called the Trap
um I I go I kind of go all over the
place I have a really good one on water
right now uh you know I I'm uh
I I like fiction I I like you know I
like factual books I'm not a big Fiction
guy I like I like can I give you um
so I read a ton I read about I only read
history basically so mostly historical
stuff okay but I'm gonna give you three
three in particular okay I I thought
that you would like you know Dan Carlin
of course Hardcore History yeah because
Dan We Know Dan Dan's a buddy of ours
really he's cool yeah I'm gonna give you
three in particular that you're gonna
dig okay the first is called The Wager
so the first two books I'm suggesting
are ship books it's about uh shipping uh
ships in the 1800s yep so the first one
is called The Wager and so these crazy
guys would sail you know their 1800s
ship yeah from England all the way down
through uh yeah Argentina and K porn yep
and they got stranded and it took them
two years to get back so you'll dig that
one the second one is called the heart
of the sea it's this uh if you've ever
Read Moby Dick you know about the whale
that sinks the ship yes there's actually
a true story behind it and so Nantucket
originally was for Quakers yeah you were
whale men yep and so these whale men
with they would they're [__] animals
you want to be talking about Savage
imagine sailing a ship with no
electricity no like way to talk to
anyone for two years all the way over
sometimes to the Pacific to Africa yeah
and they um basically their ship was in
the middle of the Pacific and it's about
how they got back to South America and
then the last one that I think you'll
really dig because I wanted to give you
three books on being a Savage the last
one was called on undaunted courage and
it's about the story of Lewis and Clark
okay
Lewis and Clark's they were they were
Savages I I like their Zone I've been up
in Washington where they're where their
their Trail was in their their hardcore
those guys are they're honorable yeah
they were bad to the [__] bones
they weren't killing anybody they were
just they were making Maps so yeah yeah
and they would meet these Natives and
they were like Hey we're we're in peace
we're going to be cool with you but it
took them two years two years and four
months to go from St Louis to the
Pacific and back and it's a crazy story
yeah so those are the three that I would
recommend for you and then I just
finished a story about uh John Wilkes
Booth the guy who killed uh Abe Lincoln
and The 12-day Manhunt to find him so I
read a ton of that stuff but yeah there
was a great particular I just had to
Ocean one too that I I can't remember
what it is that uh it's about the uh oh
what's it called I can't anyway there
was a great one a sailing one about the
race from Hobart like the race from New
Zealand uh the the one that they and
there's like is there a is there a storm
is there a storm in that one yeah crazy
storm and the and the boat and the the
guys get yeah it's it's intense on that
race
stuff yeah yeah those those stories you
know I work on my computer throughout
the day the the hardest points in my
life are if I go boxing or if I have a
hard workout and I'm like I need some
pain in my life in order to realize that
like yeah to turn down my the volume of
my daily life because my daily life is
soft so I need to read about something
hard because I can't exactly go and
experience lots of hard things so this
is why I like like reading about these
books particularly the [__] book so I
thought you'd you you'd get a kick out
of those absolutely well yeah because
those are those are I mean at Sea is a
real thing and especially those guys
weren't exactly uh watermen too like you
fall off the boat you die those guys
those guys I don't know couldn't even
swim which is crazy that's what I'm
saying they weren't exactly
like
yeah no they couldn't even swim and they
would live on a ship for 20 years of
their life they didn't even know how to
swim and also if you fell off a ship in
the ocean those those sailboats or the
ships they can't turn around exactly you
know what I mean so they just [__]
left you you're like you're done oh yeah
yeah it's it's uh that's hard core well
we we live in a pretty soft time right
now this is a pretty this is it is soft
it is soft which I'm thankful for in
some capacity oh yeah you know like
there's no doubt but like so so that's
why I think particularly young men I
think yeah well that's why they like you
I think is because they see you risking
your life on on a wave and then they
like all right well I'm not willing to
risk my life in a way but I'll go to a
pool and lift out and work uh move
weights at the bottom of the pool
because at least uh that's a little bit
of hard you know what I mean I think
that's why a lot of young men admire you
yeah well the stress is good it's it we
need it we're designed for it you know
that kind of constructive stress that
you can control the environment uh and
and because it's the other one if you
induce it you don't always have the you
don't have as much participation in the
outcome if it's just being subject if
you're being subjected to it you know
like a giant wave it can decide not to
let you up versus at least in the pool
you can always just let go your weights
and swim to the surface but we kind of
have to induce it now it's almost like
we're forced it you know a lot of the
stuff that we're doing is we're inducing
things that we were getting naturally
like we were getting it from it's like
now we don't get enough Sun so we got to
supplement and take vitamin D it's like
we're having this we're having to make
up for the fact that we're not getting a
lot of this stuff that we need
biologically and then that's and that
stress that's why the Heat and ice is
great that's why the breath work was
great that's why the pool stuff is great
because it's it's a one one of the ways
to stress to stress the system because
the system really needs for it to really
work correctly it needs a certain amount
of stress and not stress of hey I owe
taxes or hey I'm in in the traffic but
like some other stress that's a little
more
you know a little more just purely
physical so yeah I remember
um looking at uh buying a treadmill from
my desk and then I like was like what
the [__] am I doing this life I'm gonna
put a [__] walking treadmill on a
desk
I smack myself I was like this is not
the life man I'm this is literally a
hamster wheel what am I doing I'm not
buying a treadmill for a desk if I gotta
buy a treadmill for a desk I'm I'm
broken I've lost
yeah but we're almost forced into that
so we don't I mean it's like I was like
I said I was in Europe and all they do
is walk over there you know it's like
they do a lot of walking we don't walk
as nearly as much because we just don't
live in those I mean I guess in New York
you can you know where you have where
you can just if you want you can just
there you can force yourself you have to
force yourself but in Europe they really
do it a lot they do a lot of walking and
you realize how
well we we our system really does well
with walking like we're designed we're
Walkers like that's our one of our big
Evolutions was that we came up off all
fours and started walking and so our
metabolism and everything just functions
a lot better when we walk and so uh it's
it's you know it's like you said here
now we're having to like buy things so
we can stand in a room and walk it's
terrible yeah I know I I I almost bought
one and then I was going I like went
through an existential crisis I'm like
what am I doing I don't have to do this
force yourself to go for a walk in the
park or something you know make them
make time
right well I appreciate you doing this I
I really admire you I I I admire the
family you've built the the life that
you built um I'm excited that uh we were
able to talk Sam I really appreciate
your time and thank you I appreciate the
admiration and uh you know what it seems
like you're you're already you're
already uh there already so that's the
that's it
I I'm basically uh I I read history
because I like to uh see the mistakes as
well as the wins that people have made
and that's one of the reasons why I like
following you is I'm just like what wins
did he make and you know that kind of
helps point to me to the direction what
mistakes did he make I I'm gonna try and
avoid that one yeah and hopefully uh uh
it works out but you've definitely kind
of paved the path for me and a bunch of
other people so I appreciate that I
think I think that's one of the things
that makes humans unique is that we can
learn from the other people you know how
to and how not to it's like so that's
the that's a that's one one of the
things that really helps us you know is
that we can if we can I mean the best is
to learn from other people's mistakes
you know but we have a tendency
sometimes the need to make them
ourselves that's part of part of Being
Human I think too so
all right I appreciate you man thanks
for coming
[Music]
foreign